hi my name is Armand hazard Connie and
this is an introduction to Google cloud
this video is intended for use by anyone
interested in preparing for their future
careers in the next few minutes we're
going to discuss what Google cloud is
and what some student developers have
been able to create with it ready we're
gonna start by going back in time let's
pretend for a moment that we're in the
time before cloud computing and we want
to start a company to create a social
networking site you'd start by buying a
server lugging it all the way home from
the store and spending hours preparing
it with all the correct hardware and
software so it can run your company's
web app fast forward a few months and
things are looking up for your company
site the users are flooding in as your
organization's user base grows you have
to buy and install more and more servers
this is called scaling eventually you're
doing so well that the company opens up
a datacenter
next thing you know you're International
and spending billions of dollars opening
data centers all around the world sounds
like a lot of work right here's the good
news
you don't have to do any of that luckily
some companies have spent years building
some of the world's most advanced
networks of data centers cloud computing
is when these companies allow developers
to store data and run code on their
computing infrastructure Google is one
of these companies Google has data
centers all around the world that have
allowed it to scale to billions of users
these data centers how's the computing
infrastructure that powers the Google
products you may be familiar with such
as search Gmail and Google Photos Google
cloud gives you the access to the same
technology and infrastructure that
powers Google this means the Google
cloud has over 100 products and tools
and categories like compute storage and
machine learning and artificial
intelligence that seamlessly integrate
together all a click away one category
is compute these products help you
deploy code to the cloud for example we
may use a computer app engine to deploy
a social networking site another
category is storage and databases these
products help us store data retrieve and
query data in the cloud for example we
may want to store data for our
dog-walking app the dogs names and
locations in a cloud fire store data
we also have machine learning and
artificial intelligence these products
allow us to leverage Google's AI
technologies for our own applications we
can build and deploy our machine
learning models to AI platform or take
advantage of one of the easy to use pre
trained machine learning ap is like
vision or natural language so what is
Google cloud in a sentence Google cloud
lets developers build and host
applications and websites store data and
analyze data all on Google's scalable
and reliable computing infrastructure
now let's see what some student
developers have done with Google cloud a
team of student developers called
Guardian work together to help
alzheimer's patients with a gps-enabled
SmartWatch The Guardian team leveraged a
lot of the firebase platform for their
application firebase is Google clouds
comprehensive mobile development
platform the team used firebase
authentication to easily verify app
users firebase Cloud messaging to send
push notifications to different
platforms and cloud functions for
firebase to execute back-end code
without having to manage a server they
also used cloud firestore a google cloud
database to store and sync user data a
team of student developers created a
service called nagesh to help people who
are deaf or hard of hearing talk on the
phone they leverage Google clouds
text-to-speech and speech-to-text API to
convert back and forth between voice and
text and that's it let's review we
started by talking about what Google
cloud is a platform that lets developers
build and host applications and websites
store data and analyze data all on
Google's scalable and reliable computing
infrastructure then we discuss some of
the incredible projects that student
developers were able to build with these
tools when working to learn skills for
their future careers my name is Arman
hazard Connie and I can't wait to see
what you build with Google cloud
[Music]